alright guys bang bang I've got a Reuben
here with me I've known Reuben for a
while and I'm super excited about this
because I think when he's got a great
understanding of a whole bunch of stuff
that's going on and then too he's
working on some things that could be
potential solutions for all of you
sitting at home listening to this and
might need to get Rhys killed so they
sort of jumping on and doing this thank
you for having me on the show man in a
minute absolutely where you're in San
Francisco right San Francisco we met in
LA yeah you traveled a lot of places
we've traveled a lot of places but here
we are yeah absolutely
maybe let's just one thing your
background real quick and then kind of
what you guys are building today
and it would jump into kind of the more
macro environment stuff yeah so I'm the
co-founder CEO of career karma which is
a marketplace that helps people get
high-paying jobs in techni less than a
year so when people download our app
they get matched to the job training
program that's best for them and they
get coaching to not just start the
program stay in the program but also
find a job after that anybody can upload
their projects we finished Y Combinator
so we're connected to over 4,000
companies so we can send it to the top
recruiters and even in a covert 19 era
where some companies aren't hiring there
are companies that are hiring so we can
always connect them not just to the
recruiters but also individuals
themselves before this I worked at three
different startups I altschool which is
personalized education honor building
got two-sided marketplaces for nurses
I'm and then also hustle which is a
political technology text message
company and then I was an investment
banker for three years my co-founders
are bootcamp graduates we met in Atlanta
as well and then we started a podcast in
2016 called breaking into startups that
you joined as well and and and it was it
was it was highly highly acclaimed and
we essentially built this reputation I'm
of not just running a company to help
people get jobs but we are the product
we this is the product we wish that we
had when we were breaking to say you
know so when you and I met you know I
have bought a one-way ticket to San
Francisco I knew nobody three weeks
later I found a job I wrote a story
about a car breaking the stars
viologic screening of arson who talks
about kovat he reached out to me Marc
Andreessen talked about it so that's how
I started developing a big reputation
I'm through that blog and so personal
brent has been a key for us and we make
sure that um everybody in the community
then that has over 80,000 people is able
to build a personal brand as well
I mean we're currently positioning
ourselves to be the number one
destination for career advice on the
internet yeah well what's really cool
about I think your story in team Oren
and your co-founders is basically that
you guys did everything that people now
are starting to realize like this is the
path but there was no playbook for you
right like you bought the one-way ticket
and you guys all had careers before
wanting to get into technology that blog
post that you wrote the whole idea of
like hey create content if you don't
actually have the connections like those
people will find you you did that right
and then the podcast like one you guys
were early in podcast it was before I
kind of like really took off and then to
was if I remember correctly as you guys
were starting the podcast what would
happen is people would basically reach
out and say hey man thanks so much for
the content but can you help me do X can
you introduce me to somebody can you get
me in you know an interview at this
company etc and so it's almost like you
built the distribution and the audience
before you ever had a product right
that's exactly right
I'm and and it's actually even before
technology you know it it we learned it
through experience because I to a really
small school in Tennessee and nobody I
was trying to break into Investment
Banking because that's what everybody
was trying to do at the time and so I
wrote a blog telling people that I don't
qualify I got into Investment Banking
after sending out nitric hundred emails
got thousands of people coming through
and essentially like once we got into
banking we found one of our buddies he
left and became an engineer at a boot
camp called Flatiron school and Jack
Altman who now is the CEO of lattice
into the brother of Sam Altman from Y
Combinator
he was a bootcamp grant and was like
what is this boot camp thing and so like
just through osmosis and learning it
ourselves were able to figure it out so
well and I think the other lesson right
if people kind of look at the story both
individually and then what you guys have
built is it's all about the propensity
for action
right it's just the fact that you guys
would just start things and do things
and there was never a let's sit back and
play chess let's try to like you know
plan out move seven eight nine and ten
it's like hey here's where we are we
generally know where we want to go let's
what's the next what's the next move
right what's the next move on the board
and you guys have navigated this really
really well into what you're doing today
let's talk about what's going on in the
world because there's absolute chaos
going on what's kind of your take on all
this and what are you paying attention
to right now yeah so you know there's
about 10 million people ten million
Americans that have lost jobs in the
last two weeks I wish we personally
believe as a vast undercount because it
doesn't include like getting conned me
workers are freelancers and more also
some states have even stopped reporting
their daily unemployment claims at the
request of our current administration
which is kind of scary but what I like
to think deeply about is who are these
people right so it's concentrated mostly
in the service sector and and I think a
super important focus are women because
a women are 60% of hotel workers 53% of
bar staff 70% of clothing store workers
but on the positive side if you think
deeper if you look at history it can
point us to where things are going in
the labor market personally I think even
though the federal government or Federal
Reserve is predicting 47 million
Americans unemployed over the next few
months because of Corona we're looking
at the the largest reallocation of labor
since World War Two and in World War two
come to keep in mind is that the female
labor force grew by 6.5 million during
the war which in my opinion is probably
the single most important economic event
of our lifetime and so when I see the
spike in downloads inside of Korea ,
which we're getting about 15 to 20,000
download 15 to 20,000 downloads per
month its majority women that are
mothers that are coming to the platform
and it's super super interesting to
think about and so I've seen you tweet
this out you know since we are
quarantine not having time is not an
excuse yes it's difficult because we got
kids at home and things like that
we all have the ability to take
advantage of this moment to reflect to
reassess what to do with our time apply
it to a new skill set that will be
relevant in the future
yes companies are allowing people love
yes people are having hiring freezers
some of them are hiring and categories
that we will talk about later related to
anti fragility but if you really we I
can I'd not Nostradamus but I can
probably bet that there will be more
technology in the future and if there is
more technology in the future you're
probably gonna need to be able to speak
the language of tech and engineering and
things like that and so I think there's
a huge huge huge opportunity to think
about how to take advantage of these
moments but people are suffering and
it's gonna require more than the skill
sets because yeah yeah in this I think
right is look it's already bad right 10
million Americans in two weeks is bad
it's likely to get worse right and you
know I keep kind of hammering on this
point the economy is not gonna recover
until we get out of our hopes right it's
just that's how it works you can't spend
money can't have jobs can't have
businesses right we're all sitting at
home so that is hack there that has to
be balanced with the virus right you
have the health crisis and so there's
not a black-and-white solution it's not
okay turning back on the economy forget
the health piece right and it's not shut
economy off on a percent and only worry
about the health piece so we gotta
navigate that but what ends up happening
here is now we have millions of people
tens of millions probably at the end of
this that are sitting at home unemployed
and part of that is there will be stress
financially there will be challenges
there will be things where people need
assistance relief etc but also there
will be a group of people who retrain
their skills they switch careers right
they uses as an opportunity whether they
want it to do that already or not they
see the opportunity so I guess that's
really where I want to focus on like
what can people do right part of what
you guys do is actually help people find
the right roles and kind of training and
skill sets but also I think that there's
this element of what the mindset first
you have to switch your mindset because
really what ends up happening is if you
don't switch your mindset you're not
gonna stick it out like you like Rubin
could be the best coach in the world if
I just don't want
new it I'm not gonna finish right
mmm-hmm that's exactly right so I I love
that you borrow at that point because we
tell people that most barriers in life
or psychological not technical you know
most people don't finish what they start
and as you're going through this process
at some people a certificate or degree
it's not gonna get you a job
and neither is learning how to code
right the way that you communicate the
way that you tell your story the way
that you brand yourself personally the
projects that you build the the way that
you work with other people care
programming how you handle the
whiteboarding and if you think that all
of that type of stuff matters I'm in so
what I would say is part of the reason
why when people download our app the
first thing that they do is share their
career goal and their current level of
experience with us and a three-minute
profile called fast-track at the bottom
of the app it's because we can't coach
you if we don't understand what your
current level is once they do that then
the app will match them with the right
individuals that will help them get to
where they want to go but even then a
lot of people drop out if they don't
have guidance so we created a system
called the 21-day ACK challenge that you
all can look at on Twitter where people
are tweeting all the time and during
that those 21 days which are five
minutes a day check-ins
through the app they get put into a
group called a squad that's an
accountability system that's a daily
reminder that where they can self
organize their own study groups to make
sure that they start and finish the
program or encourage themselves through
this process I think the the thing I
really like about what you've written up
here that a lot of people don't think
about is that most people during this
process especially if they've been
shocked by an unemployment situation
they experience self-doubt and we call
it a solid Dow impostor syndrome and
it's a feeling where you are fully
qualified to do the work but you trick
yourself or you tell yourself that you
don't belong and so the whole reason why
career come is not just in matching
platform to boot camps but a LinkedIn
for the invisible workforce in the
social network is because you need
community in order to make it through
that's part of the biggest values of
schools and why only five to fifty
percent of people complete the 100
million online courses that people have
taken on the internet in the last seven
years
yeah it is really crazy too because I
think part of specially taught technical
right so let's say that I just had a you
know let's use to kind of an egregious
example so I'm a bartender my bar is now
shut down by government mandate the
owner comes to me and says hey you are
unemployed now I literally can't pay you
so I go I get my unemployment claim in
now I'm waiting then trying to figure
out when is this gonna end and so I
started thinking about a career a lot of
people I think the first question that
they would ask themselves if you said
why don't you go be a computer scientist
is I don't understand how to code I'm
not technical that's really hard right
like the mental barrier of just what is
that is so big whereas I think what you
guys are really trying to do is say look
there's millions of other people who
figured this out right there's no reason
why you can't but what you need is you
need persistence you need discipline you
need people to tell you you can do it
and kind of you guys provide not only
here's where you should go get the
training but here's the support system
that goes into that and it seems to be
like that support system may actually be
more important in some ways than simply
hey put this you know line of code here
put this line of code there right
absolutely absolutely absolutely and I
think on top of that if you think about
it to your point people are aware that
tech is where the jobs are or where
they're going to be but most people
aren't aware of the roles in tech the
skills that are required to get those
roles and if you think about a coding
boot camp like if you're if you're even
if you're Don Draper you're in your if
you're Don Draper from Mad Men you made
the best marketing and you reach the
audience that wants to learn how to code
your coding book tip is not gonna
resonate if those people don't even know
what code is alright and so what we tell
them is like we created this community
you can see on the home page you see
questions all the time and discussions
of people asking questions in the
beginner section about what is code what
is the boot camp what is this and then
other people answering it which creates
trust credibility creates to network
effect and we get bigger and bigger and
bigger and stronger stronger there's
more and more people make it through so
yes support system the the trust of
people helping people is absolutely the
biggest key yeah and I guess really
right now like
as we're seeing the unemployment numbers
kind of continue to accelerate what what
do you think is likely right so you
talked a little bit about women are
gonna be disproportionately affected by
this because they're the ones who have
the service and hospitality type
occupations are there other things that
you're looking at or paying attention to
and the unemployment numbers or just
that alone is is kind of the big
takeaway and then it becomes okay
there's a problem let's go try to solve
it well think of a few things like so
first I think that like historically we
think about like the education and labor
piece as separate I think about there's
a Department of Labor Department of
Education when I think they're actually
both interconnected right there's a
reason why companies have like dedicated
University recruiting programs right but
that's only a limited portion of the
world and even if all tech couples have
dropped their college degree requirement
it's very difficult for them to identify
talent that didn't go to a college
background so when I think about
education and the virus no education has
changed more in the last two weeks than
last 200 years
there's 3.5 billion people unlocked on
the school closures have now affected
1.4 billion people in forced 900
colleges to go online and they were
already struggling to keep in touch with
the curriculum to help them get jobs and
College has not historically been
outcomes driven I'm not saying college
is not valuable because I'm a college
graduate I learned a lot from college
you get to open up your mind and a bunch
of other things but it's not focus on
getting jobs so what I think is going to
happen is no students are now
questioning the cost of tuition I think
their education systems is gonna really
start focusing on becoming outcomes
driven where the only reason why people
are going to your program whether it's
college a boot camp or self taught is to
get a job there will be some people that
want to do it just for shits and giggles
which is great but for the most part
people want to get money and so if
that's the case then the things that
people were giving people a lot of heat
about before this Ron income share
agreements or deferred tuition model or
a money back
guarantee model if they don't get a job
I'm gonna come back and vote you're
still gonna have people that are gonna
have opinions on both sides but there's
enough people that have gotten jobs to
an outcome driven model where I think
it's gonna accelerate if you point to
history as well I think that is going to
be inevitable for government step in and
help
on the education side so if I was an
educator right now I'll probably be
doing everything that I could to focus
on outcomes and the only outcome that
matters is getting people jobs and your
completion rates right and so I think
that's important the other thing that is
important to understand is that it's not
enough to give people a free education
because I in my opinion I think income
share degree ms money-back guarantees
all that type of stuff is a temporary
solution actually think the cost of
education is are going to go down to
zero I'm like it isn't like most of the
world right that's another conversation
I think that even if you have your
education at zero like we said earlier
this parents there's people that have
rent to pay right so yes even if I can
go to school for free I gotta pay bills
and so you're starting to see a lot of
job training programs in boot camps like
thankful for example they just got
acquired by cheque for hundred million
dollars or eight hundred million dollars
what there are now so whatever they're
providing a living stipend where they'll
pay you $400 a month through the program
if you've been affected by Corona
they'll give you a laptop so if you go
through the program there's different
scholarships and things like that
because it's not enough to just have
access to training you need additional
support sometimes and so I think I think
those are the main things that I'm
thinking about and I don't I also think
what we're gonna see is clay Christensen
rest in peace he actually already said
that half of the colleges were gonna go
away and I think that this is going to
accept this whole Cove in 19 suggestion
isn't going to accelerate that trend
I don't think all colleges are going to
disappear but when you see institutions
like Stanford they have billion-dollar
numbers found that's doing hiring
freezes and tuition costs and things
like that I think that is a major
Harbinger about what's going to happen
with the rest of higher education and if
I was
they just in one sense I think whoever's
listening to this just start thinking
about the education system and the labor
system as interconnected and to start
thinking deeper about places outside of
college because LinkedIn only has like
600 million people and there's about 8
billion people in the world and will
they only 10 billion by 2050 yeah what's
really crazy to me I think so there's
two pieces in there that kind of
immediately once stoked my my anger and
the other you know great point the first
is the universities are a complete sham
in one way which is most of them are
actually asset management firms that
have a school right what I mean by that
is they've got a billion plus dollar
endowments that it has a very very
advantageous tax structure to it but
then you see this quote rainy day fund
or this thing that is supposed to be
there for the education for the students
for the teachers etc all of the sudden
when we do have that rainy day they say
you know what we're not gonna hire more
people we're gonna freeze raises we're
gonna get rid of our vendors and then we
know that that's going to lead to them
firing the cafeteria staff or the
janitorial service workers etc and so
what happens is like why do you have
that thirty billion dollar endowment
right and another song that actually
will step in and they'll use it the
right way and do the right thing but I
think it's just exposing kind of the B
incentive structure right and kind of
what it's actually there for and what
it's not for so I think that's the first
thing but then the second thing you said
that's really interesting is you said
earlier that there's been more
innovation in education last two weeks
in the last two hundred years
right and I think that that's very tied
into this idea of outcomes based
education which I think most people
today would admit College has 50%
education benefits 50% social benefits
right and part of this comes down to how
can we actually get people the education
benefit or I'm sorry the social benefit
right that the things that help you
would learn from other people open your
mind mentally kind of mature your brain
all that kind of stuff without requiring
you to pay fifty thousand dollars a year
take on a bunch of debt and also move
some
to go do it right it just feels like
those two things where it's previously
been thought to be incompatible with
each other over time is actually going
to be figured out and this may be the
catalyst that does that
ya know I think it's a very exciting
time you see the growth of things like
Khan Academy out school and a bunch of
other things like that that are what I
think kind of ketamine I saw an article
I said they normally get like 18 million
downloads a month I think it's like
three or four times and they said
because a corona is that's that number
is about to increase by seven or eight
times which makes their their bill
they're like server bill like tens of
millions of dollars or twenty over
twenty million dollars a year which is
insane but it's awesome that people are
excited in like one of my good venture
careful friends Adam ara
Herrera Cowboys she said EdTech Oh sexy
again which is always should have been
and that never one out of style but like
education is key work is is also key to
occupy identity like occupation our
identity and something else that we
didn't cover about this that I think is
important to understand is that that I
think deeply about is I think our labor
market has now entered into free agency
equivalent of the sports world right if
you think about the sports world if
you're like a player you would join the
the team in your hometown you will go to
the school that you went to in your
hometown and you play with that team
forever and just win a bunch of rings
right but then free agency came around
and then like if you're LeBron and
Cleveland and Miami Yan LA and you just
you just went everywhere right and I
think what we're entering into which
people were talking about this before
karana with the fourth Industrial
Revolution is lifelong learning where
people don't stay at one company forever
they don't stay at one school forever
they go from company company to company
and school school or school people that
Reed Hoffman talked about this with
alliances and tours of duty and how you
know whatever you want to be in the
future you're gonna spend a little bit
of time from here to here to here so if
there's no loyalty to a school or a
company and no loyalty to yeah no
loyalty to a school comes in the car
education has gone down then what
becomes valuable is your network of
people that are going through this
process with you drain work and your
identity is not always tied to your role
for some people it used to be like I'm a
doctor I'm a lawyer I work for this big
firm king of Spaulding if I'm a lawyer
like that's dope but like now it's like
I'm pop right you know I'm I'm Reuben
like I'm like whoever you are that's
what makes you cool and then when people
say your name what do they think like
before I thought Facebook paid to
snapchat right now I think Facebook page
of snapchat Bitcoin mega podcast
megastar right so when people say your
name what do people think I think that
matters when people Google your name
what pops up
and so I think as these people that are
leaving work or considering the change
start reflecting on what they should do
in the labor market or if there's
entrepreneurs that are focused on
helping these people these are the
things that you should be thinking about
in my opinion yeah this I think is a
mental shift like you mentioned Bellagio
earlier he was talking about like look
there's this shift underway from what
the Industrial Revolution right to now
we're entering like the information
revolution right and he laid out a whole
bunch of things everything from like
internet homeschooling to you know the
the death of kind of mainstream media
it's a social media all those kind of
stuff but really what ends up happening
is many of the people who have recently
been laid off are actually the last ones
to recognize these shifts right people
who work hourly wages who work for small
businesses who are the service or
hospitality or travel industry etc
they're the last ones to benefit from
this stuff in some weird almost awkward
way because they have been you know I've
lost their jobs in that Industrial Age
type company or a role now all of a
sudden they're presented an opportunity
to try to make the switch now their
short-term pain in their right which is
really I think where people are focused
like how do we how do we bridge that gap
how do we try to solve some of that pain
for them but ultimately what ends up
happening is the ones who choose to make
that shift I think will come out you
know a year two three years later and be
in a much better position
right and I think you guys see that on a
daily basis with the people who kind of
come in and say look I want to find
training I want to find a new skill set
so that I can go get a job at a
technology company and make more money
and be in a better position in life yeah
I mean you know what's interesting I'm
saying so another MBA is cancelled and I
saw cancelled I actually see a lot of
professional athletes downloaded in the
career comma app and like really
interested in working for like gaming
companies not like you know shout out to
delay more play versus I was killing
killing the eSports game Michael Seibel
will I will Twitter whatever like you
see a lot of a lot of people that have
been laid off from tech companies that
are like in a sector that might be
travel-related
that see the opportunity they got saving
saved up so these aren't just
blue-collar you see white-collar people
as well being like oh wow this is a I've
always wanted to do this let me figure
out how to level up and I also see
employers stepping in as well which i
think is super interesting to understand
there's a great report by Georgetown
called colleges at the beginning and
they talk about how the u.s. spends 1.1
trillion dollars on workforce training
every year and how employers are
essentially our largest educator and so
what you're starting to see is um
there's things called micro work where
while you're going through a program
they'll give you work to do so you can
get some experience while you're going
through the program
I'm obviously internships and
apprenticeships are a very big deal
Adobe did something called Adobe Digital
Academy where they partnered with
General Assembly well they'll pay all of
your things and then they'll hire you at
the end which is very interesting
there's another company called katha
light um that's pretty interesting
that's doing a lot of staffing models
well they'll take the work from the
companies and help them learn I'm and
then level them up because a lot of
these people are doing your talent and
the companies that are hiring sometimes
are looking for senior talent so there's
a on-ramp or some kind of way to
standardize that that's going to be
interesting and you're seeing more and
more companies step up in that regard so
I'm excited about that too yeah how long
do you see on average it takes for
someone to get retrained right so let's
say that yesterday I lost my job and I
say hey you know what mentally I'm in
the spa
I want to make a change I know it's
gonna be hard but I'm ready to do it
what does that look like what am I
looking at from a time perspective yeah
so on average is about 3 to 12 months so
if you're doing it for time it'll take
you about 3 to 6 months if you're doing
it part-time it'll be about 6 to 12
months for time is about 6 to 12 hours a
day
part-time is about 4 yeah
4 times 6 to 12 hours a day part-time is
about 4 to 6 hours a day the days of the
week whereas five to seven days really
depends on which program that you go to
and again you can see all these
different curriculums at krikawa that
concise schools but for the most part
it's about 3 to 12 months there are some
programs that have 18-month programs arm
as well but for the most part that's the
average I am seeing in this type of
environment I'm more programs with
longer durations just because there are
some people that have different learning
styles it might take a little bit longer
to capture different concepts and yeah
and the ones that are more concentrated
in shorter are usually people that have
a prior background or at least some some
prior knowledge or they'll give you a
part course but pretty much every job
training program that we work with every
book kind of we work with assumes you
know nothing and they're designed to
take you from zero to 100 real quick got
it it didn't I guess or these things
where I'm required to like move so let's
say I'm living in Topeka Kansas right
and versus New York City obviously a
little bit different or can I do this
stuff remote for the most part yeah so
that's an interesting question we um I
think everybody should you should link
to this episode on this report but we
did a report called the state of the
bootcamp market 2020 I mean you can
actually see the concentration of
locations for the bootcamp
most of them are actually in New York
and most alkalizing in New York or San
Francisco those are two places but you
can see it across the board but if you
look at the history of boot camps
it started off only in person pay money
up front or alone very similar to
everything else I mean it was only
full-time then as more and more people
started getting into it then there
started to be the flexibility with the
part-time versus for time then some
people started doing
online and online started growing faster
than in-person and having not just the
same outcomes as in-person but even
better outcomes did in person then we
realized that the amount of people that
have 10 or $15,000 to pay for a boot
camp or front is limited so then you had
innovation with income share agreements
and deferred tuition and money-back
guarantees and so the short answer is
yes everybody can do it online remotely
which is a blessing and this dnase but
without what I'll say about it as well
that I think is very interesting to
understand is it's not just part time
before time you have self-paced courses
as well with mentorship so that's that
that's how I think about it yeah you got
it
and I guess do you see people who are
good at using the remote learning
programs also end up going into remote
work jobs like it's like is there a hey
I either live in a geographic location
where it's difficult for me to move for
whatever reason and so I want the remote
learning end job or some people do
remote learning go and actually they
want to work in an office like what's
the connection there between the the
program that they're in to get retrained
and then where they end up actually
getting a job I say yes and no so
there's two recent episodes of people on
career Commodus as a black woman they
try to go to college for ten years and
she went to a boot camp in person in
Atlanta and got his remotely a stitch
fix making ninety eight thousand five
hundred dollars when she came to us he
knew she did not know what code was she
didn't even have a laptop in three weeks
we got accepted into four schools she
started and then she got that job so
that's an example of in person and chose
a remote work job and then we have
another guy who did an online boot camp
they also received a living stipend his
name is Jarek Warren and you can find it
on the podcast and he got a job making
$145,000 but he started in and and
Modesto and California
he started the program and then he
landed the job in New York on a move to
New York I mean that was going from
online to in person so I wouldn't say
those two things are directly correlated
people do an online remote or in person
in person but it really comes down to
what you want for your family and your
lifestyle which is why when you download
the app we ask you from day one what do
you want when you fill out the profile
and then our technology can get an
understanding of what your goal is and
then we'll create a blueprint for you
and give you the people that can get you
there got it
and I guess when you throw out numbers
like ninety eight thousand one hundred
forty five thousand that seems
impossible to people done right there's
there's some people who say hey that's
my expectation there's other people who
say that would be incredible but like
how do I go from making thirty five
forty thousand dollars a year to harm
forty five thousand that's that just
seems insurmountable one I guess is just
like what do you see kind of on average
right as people come out of these
schools and then to is you know kind of
what's your advice to the person who's
sitting there saying like it sounds
great but I it's just not for me I just
can't do it yeah so on average we see
pay ranges between seventy to a hundred
thousand dollars depending on where you
located your locators what I used to say
but now because of remote work I'm not
telling people that the fastest growing
commuters no commute so if you you know
landed out of somewhere that's paying
that you'll get that money I'm saying I
think because of cover 19 salary
adjustments are probably gonna change
but we still see people that are getting
between seventy two hundred thousand
dollars we'll see how that plays out the
reason why these guys pay so much money
is because the demand is high it was
high before coverage just so people know
the number since we're talking about
this there was over half a million open
jobs only fifty thousand people
graduating four-year universities and by
2024 is supposed to be one point four
million open jobs and only four hundred
thousand people graduating for four-year
universities which means that over a
million people got to get a job from
something that's not college right what
that self taught bootcamp or whatever
now the demand is even higher and we
know that the university system is not
gonna be able to keep up with this type
of it demand
I mean that's not taking shots at
universities again but that demand and
supply difference is what keeps the
price high right so there's still
competition with that said since there's
a lot of layoffs not just from Junior
Talent
Latta tech companies driving talent or
reducing salaries and so now as a junior
engineer you're also competing with
senior people and this is the same
dynamic I faced when I was leaving
college as well I left college during
the financial crisis - and I was a guy
that didn't go to Natalie's school bad
GPA blah blah blah
competing with laid-off investment
bankers to prove that I can do this
thing and so with that said for the
people that are like oh no I can't do
this I just want to encourage you to
understand that the reason that you're
gonna get this job is not because of
your coding skills or the certificate or
degree that you have it's being
authentically who you are and at this
gonna sound super corny we're all
natural as something that's not natural
to everyone else think deeply about the
problems that you've experienced in your
life this is very entrepreneurial to
like think deeply about the problems
you've experienced in your life that a
company is currently solving or where
you could get some experience or where
you can be seen as an esteemed person
where you can be an expert on that
subject and then focus on building
solutions to those problems while you're
going through your boot camp you might
end up finishing the boot camp and not
wanting to get a job in it but now you
have a skill set that you could apply
for your softwar that makes you better
at you what you really want to do
whether there's a teacher or or or
whatever which is also a noble
profession right so it doesn't hurt to
try what we tell people is like if all
let's say all million of pops listeners
right now wanna start a coding bootcamp
today just download the career [ __ ] app
and if you try to get a job in 2020 and
you don't the worst thing that happened
is that you learn something and you
didn't pay any money which is you know
knowledge pays the best interest that's
what about Frank listed right so yeah
investing in yourself right take
advantage of that yeah and I think part
of this you've got some thoughts on my
kind of the anti fragility type mindset
right and kind of how that can be built
but part of this is there's a lot of
people if you sit them down and say
what are your skills they'll immediately
rattle off what they do professionally
right but they actually have other
skills and and people always ask me you
know what do you think I should do I
said look I can't tell you exactly what
you like to do ultimately there's
something that you do whatever it is
that other people hate doing that you
actually enjoy doing
you probably enjoy it because you're
either good at it or you don't eat
you're not even very good at it but you
will become good at it because you
naturally will do in your free time you
don't look at it as work etc and people
are scared to go after that like that
like there's like oh that can't be a job
right and one of the best examples is
like the whole eSports stuff rhaggy you
brought up earlier of just like how many
parents told their kids you know stop
playing video games you gotta go get a
job kids making millions of dollars
playing a video straight I was one of
those kids I don't know when I was in
high school I played again called kind
of straight I wanted to be a pro role
play this was before Twitter I was on
out in the cyberathlete amateur league
and I was sneaked away to play the video
game at night now since big ole industry
people yeah not exactly right you know I
love it and so I guess really um as
people are going through this then like
how do you think about the anti
fragility you know coming out of what
looks like it's gonna be a pretty bad
financial crisis yeah so for people that
aren't aren't familiar with the term
anti fragile it comes from the scene
tell em shout out to my my my buddy kaha
and he put me onto that book before all
this happening so I think let's cause
about talks about being anti fragile
which is a category of things that not
only gain from chaos but they need it in
order to survive and flourish I do
believe that boot camps are anti fragile
and education does Drive during times
like this and when I when I reflect on
the term anti fragile it reminds me of
the original breaking in the starters
post that we wrote and when I thought
about the companies that I wanted to
work for I pointed out in the article
and everybody could look this up I wrote
it in 2014
things goes in cycles right that you
just tweeted this tool and there's
there's bull markets and there's bear
markets right if you think about the
things that Tech has created so far now
is a little bit different but when I
the article there's mostly things that
are nice to have like you know Facebook
snapchat like cool like I would say
something some of those things are
starting to become need to have but
before it's more like tick-tock like
entertainment like let's have a good
time right why is he talking about
making something people want now
everybody watch someone make it so make
something people need right because when
I picked the companies that I wanted to
work for I wanted to focus on companies
that are solving problems that are
fundamental to life and I put on the
article Maslow's hierarchy of needs and
if you look at the three companies that
I work for so far they are in education
healthcare and politics that is by
design I deliberately chose to go there
because I knew that those categories are
places where it does not matter what
economy is happening there will be
strong economic activity there whether
they're making money or not who knows
are some strong growth there and whether
they're making money or not that's
another question but we're able to take
a category that's fundamental solving
people's problems so when I think about
myself or your one of your listeners is
thinking about picking anti fragile
categories think about your own Massell
hike of knees if you drew the Maslow's
hierarchy of needs
where at the top is about like belonging
and fulfillment and self-actualization
and I'm not going to go into that whole
thing my mom's a psychologist that's
what I think about it a lot but if you
focus on like housing the roof over your
head food education you know financing
you know like things like that you know
what what is an area where you can
become the best in the world in and then
just dive in that direction what I'll
say about this too is don't worry about
perfection
I think our education system has
historically focused on us on being
perfect and getting the best grades and
the perfect SATs and if you look at my
eighties my SATs are straight garbage I
was the one that was making Patterson on
my SATs I didn't care about it right but
I bring it up because you really want to
just focus on being directionally
correct just like go in that direction
and if you shoot for the moon even if
you miss you'll land them on the Stars
and I'm not here to do the nothing
teller podcast which I hope that you're
gonna be able to do but just everybody
here listening look up the term anti
fragile we all know that Black Swan
events happen if we study economics and
cover 19 is a Black Swan event but like
Kennedy said you know there's a the
Chinese character for for crisis one
stroke is danger the other one's
opportunity right so we never want to
let a crisis or an opportunity going
away so take full advantage for sure and
I think part of what you're talking
about like being directionally correct
there's two things that are really key
here so the first is one I always tell
people that whenever they get the
opportunity to join a company right when
you're coming out of school you either
want a one go start a company if you
have that risk appetite and that's what
you want to do or do is if you're gonna
go join a company don't go join the
IBM's of the world I think it was Adam
Nash maybe when you're the wolf front
piece they wrote a blog post that was
based like go join the like series a or
series B company that most people feel
like it's gonna be the next uber the
next Airbnb the next Facebook the next
you know Twitter or whatever because
what ends up happening is you get inside
it's easy to move around if you're good
you'll get more responsibility over time
you'll learn from a lot of people and
then you are personally benefiting from
the success of the company so when you
go to leave now you're known as oh he
was early at Twitter he was early at
this she was early here whatever and
there's this big reputational boost
along with the information and
responsibility boost you get by being
early in a place that grows really fast
ends up being successful that's exactly
why I mean Sam Altman talks about like
the value of having a W on your record
I'm an even Gary 10 he just tweeted
something yesterday I'm talking about
how the rate of learning is the most
valuable startup compensation right the
the the only differentiator between the
startup and anything else is a growth
right but it's not just about moving
fast
it's about your speed of iteration and
if you're an individual that has chosen
to work at a company that's growing and
iterating quickly and your rate of
learning is growing exponentially that
knowledge that experience pays off very
well and then if you picked right on top
of
you get that W on your work record you
are essentially not immortal but like
you're like you're good in the labor
force like you'll be straight you're not
gonna go hungry so you should title this
how to be immortal before before we
finished up I want to quickly touch on
you mentioned earlier these living
stipends that some of the boot forces
boot camps are providing for people and
how it kind of ties into a universal
basic income except you got a bunch of
thoughts there maybe elaborate on that
yeah so there's a there's a great it's
gonna sound kind of weird it's a great
Playboy magazine article that dr. Martin
Luther King did with I never thought I
would hear that sentence right yeah it's
actually a awesome awesome post article
talking about automation okay
and he talks about how Tech is creating
and destroying jobs and if something in
black and white will be affected unless
something grand and imaginable is done
and career karma is our version of that
grand and imaginable thing that's going
to help everybody but the reason why I
talk about universal basic income is
because it's a concept that dr. Martha
King brought up in that piece our
government system has talked about it
for a long time not just our government
system it's a bipartisan issue many
people have talked about it well that
thing yesterday I was really really
excited to see what what uh what Jack
Dorsey did with the billion dollar
commitment out to to help solve or kill
the virus right and I just flattened the
curve but just completely demolished it
so he committed a billion dollars
towards this cover 19 pandemic but the
other thing that I don't think everybody
caught that that jumped out to me is he
also mentioned he not only just tweeted
days gonna done it he made a Google Doc
that's been transparent which i think is
awesome leadership you could see where
the money's going but he also said that
he's gonna after this is done he's gonna
focus on girls education
and universal basic income all right um
there's the the reason why I like both
of those things goes back to my point
about women labor force in this women
period I love my mama mama's boy and I
think that women are the most powerful
in the world there's more women than men
in the world they're more educated often
they mature faster and what's super cool
about universal basic income is that it
goes back to the point about even if you
have things that are free or even if you
have access to skills tests or companies
there's certain things that are required
in order to live and so universal basic
general for the people that don't know
essentially money given to you by the
government so that you can have your
basic necessities covered Alaska
currently has this in place Native
American tribes also had this in place
my buddy might Michael Tubbs who's the
mayor of Stockton has run an experiment
for universal Baker's basic income Y
Combinator has run an experiment on
universal basic income I like what give
directly which is non profits done
related to this it's really really
exciting but imagine a world where all
your basic needs are taken care of like
you don't have to worry about riot food
or clothes if you don't have to worry
about rent food or clothes how would you
use your time all right and so I think I
think time is a good concept it kind of
like leads me to a whole nother place
because we think deeply about like how
would he how would we exchange value if
money didn't exist and I think there's a
really good movie called end time my
favorite movies you know and for the
people that don't know about it it's a
movie where money doesn't exist and the
rich people got nothing but time and the
poor people are always running out of it
right so how do we take our time sitting
at home quarantine to invest it and
create more time in the in the future
time is literally money and I think that
universal basic income can give us more
time and I just focus on ourselves but
to to make the world a better place I
mean I'm really excited about that
concept
so that movie's got Justin Timberlake in
it so anything with Justin Timberlake
but on top of that the whole concept
there of the rich people got nothing but
time right the poor people running out
is when they run out of time they die
right and it's one of those movies where
the first time I ever watched it a lot
of it was over my head I just didn't
understand what was going on you know
and it was entertaining but whatever
watch the second time couple of months
later and I was like wait a minute and I
started to see some of the underlying
themes right what they were trying to
really say time is money also by about
the third time I watched it I remember
saying like holy [ __ ] this is probably
one of the most prophetic movies ever in
that it really hammers home core
concepts for life that if you can
understand those concepts and apply them
in your life it'll it'll chase what you
think about your time what you do for a
living
etc and it's all kind of masked as this
like I don't know weird like Justin
Timberlake movie right and then like to
put a bow on it
and and how like universal basic income
can create time it's not something that
currently exists for everybody right now
and who knows that the government
approves it they've already approved a
stimulus but living stipends currently
do exist and everybody that does
download the Kirkham app can be eligible
to receive a living stipend and more and
more people are doing this and they can
range between a thousand to four
thousand dollars even people that are
disabled I think the government already
has something called like vocational
rehabilitation programs were they'll pay
for your education and things like that
but take full advantage of living
stipends just google it and there
probably will be something that exists
the other thing that's interesting too
is outplacement services as well where
if you get laid off a company will pay
for your training I'm and then take
advantage of the living stipend and then
you're in a pretty interesting place so
yeah I love it man all right this is
super helpful there's a lot of people I
mean literally millions of people
sitting at home right now who who are
wondering what they should be doing any
last pieces of advice for them just as
they're sitting there wondering
what do I do I think the last piece of
advice that I would say is um listen to
more episodes on Popp's podcasts because
I think it's super important to
understand what's happening in the world
cuz it's changing so fast and you know
we've known each other for a long time
for good reason like we were aligned and
we understand how these work and and
there's you're always making sure that
you're not just benefiting yourself
you're helping others I encourage them
to find other podcasts as well that
educate them to sign up different
newsletters watch some YouTube videos
check out the breaking stars podcast as
well take some time to spend time with
your family with the babies as well and
and and to realize that your
occupational identity is not tied to
what you do and try to think about what
your purpose is collecting this is a
great opportunity to do that yeah I am
one I appreciate the kind words but I
think that if somebody asked me who
who's helped more people as silk about
you guys done a fantastic job of doing
that so I will link to everything I can
and then hopefully people will take
advantage what you guys bilks think it's
super important where can they find you
you online Twitter anywhere yes
Twitter's the main place on Ruben Harris
our UB and har is same thing on
Instagram I was on a fro tech laughter
day so sometimes I do some things on
Instagram um I have a snapchat but I
don't really use it but those are the
main places are if you want to send me
an email through been at career canva
calm I'm especially please please please
email me if you have a clear Cobin 19
offering that you want to provide to
people to work as they're transitioning
think deeply about what could you do for
millions of people that are
transitioning careers and if you have
something to support them let me know
because I can blow that out and get them
to a lot of people and make sure that
some things can happen for them awesome
you spend more time on Twitter Instagram
now Twitter for sure actually have like
black limiters on my Instagram for like
10 minutes a day because literally like
well if they're scrolling with the new
smoking I like that well it's a bad
thing but yeah it makes sense
but I but I do squirrel that on Twitter
that's my guilty pleasure but it's also
like I got a know what's going on so
ever since covered I just been glued to
it I had a blocker on Twitter too but I
took it off because I don't know what's
going on I love a babe well listen I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this you guys are building something
awesome so hopefully some people go take
advantage of it and I hope people learn
from this Thank You Maya likewise